[Music]
hey guys i'm chef joya and i'm an expert
at transitioning non-vegans to vegan
food today we're making vegan southern
fried chicken
maple collards and candy yams using five
ingredients or less let's go ahead and
get started
so we're gonna start off by heating our
oil and we're using grapeseed oil for
this recipe we're gonna add that to the
pot so for my southern fried chicken we
are going to use oyster mushrooms i
absolutely love oyster mushrooms because
it has a very meaty texture now you want
to make sure that you clean your
mushrooms with a towel you don't want to
put these in water because it will
absorb it and your mushrooms will become
mushy now the chicken can be any size
that you want we're going to have some
that smaller pieces so all you have to
do is break them up right at the base
and you want to keep that base intact
because that's going to hold your
mushroom together so i'm going to use
poultry seasoning because it has all of
the herbs and spices you need so we're
going to get that mixed in the bowl this
is going to just taste amazing it's not
going to take like fried mushrooms
because all of the seasonings is going
to taste just like fried chicken so
we're going to take half of our seasoned
flour and we're going to add this into a
shallow pan because we're going to need
a wet and a dry batter so for our wet
batter we're going to add our club soda
to our seasoned flour and we're going to
whisk that in there so we want it to be
about the texture of pancake batter
because it is going to thicken up over
time i love the club soda because it
gives the chicken extra crispy and a
lighter texture so we're going to put it
into our dry batter and we're going to
give that a nice little coat so we're
going to take our chicken pieces and put
it in our wet batter and once we get
those coated evenly we're going to put
it back in our dry batter so now that we
have our oil nice and hot and our
chicken pieces have been fully covered
we're going to add this to the pan now
we want to start with our bigger pieces
first because it takes longer to cook
now you want to get as many chicken
pieces that you can get in the pan
without overcrowding the pan because i
will slow down the process of your
cooking your vegan chicken
and just like with anything it'll make
it really oily and you don't want that
we want this to be light and crispy
all right so we're going to turn over
our first piece of chicken
like if you don't tell anybody they
wouldn't even know that it's vegan like
it looks just like fried chicken so we
got all our pieces turned we're going to
let that cook for about another two
minutes all right and it should be nice
and golden brown and we're going to use
the paper towel so we can drain any
excess oil this looks absolutely
delicious i cannot believe that i got
this recipe down to five ingredients all
right let's get into this chicken
this is absolutely delicious like look
at this you can give this to somebody
that's not vegan it looks like meat do
you see this do you see this like matter
of fact don't even when you make this
don't even tell people that it's vegan
chicken make sure they don't have a
mushroom allergy though please
let's go ahead and get started on our
other sides
all right let's start by heating our oil
in a pan and next we're going to add our
onion and we're going to slice them so
you can slice them or dice them it's
just whatever your preference is all
right so we're going to add our onions
to the oil so this is going to cook down
for about three minutes so your onions
are almost translucent and then we're
going to add our collard greens so i add
half of my collard greens to the pan and
i'm going to go ahead and mix that
around so let's go ahead and get that
cooked down and then we're going to add
the remaining half so we have this first
half almost covered with our infused oil
and onions and we're going to add our
remaining collard greens to the pen any
time i cook collard greens it reminds me
of my mom collard greens is my one of my
mom's cooking staples she's known for
her collard greens in wisconsin she's
won every competitions that she competed
in my mom even ships me collard greens
to north carolina hey mama don't forget
this year so once we get these coated
all the way we're going to go ahead and
add our seasonings the vegan bouillon
i'm going to use you'll find at the
asian market so let's go ahead and get
that mixed in there and then next we're
going to go ahead and add our seasoning
i like to use an all-purpose seasoning
so i'm going to add that to my pot and
give that a nice stir now i haven't
added any water to the pan but you can
see that there is water that's coming
out because the greens is going to
release the water but i do add a little
bit more and we're going to turn this on
high and once it starts to boil we're
going to change it to simmer and let it
cook for 30 minutes this is 2 pounds of
calories you wouldn't think that but
it's not going to cook down like spinach
[Music]
now that our collard greens are done to
our desired tenderness it is time to add
our maple syrup i started using maple
syrup instead of sugar because it gives
it more of a robust flavor so now that
our greens are done we're going to go
ahead and put it in our bowl and we're
gonna get all of the liquid in the
bottom of our pot that is called the pot
liquor i can't have greens without the
pot liquor okay so we have our maple
collards
ready to go and it's time to give it a
taste
test this is real good even if you cook
collard greens with meat there is
absolutely no need to this is the
perfect collard green recipe for any day
we're going to start off with our peeled
candy yams and we're going to slice them
about a half inch thick and we're gonna
use about four to five medium to large
whatever you prefer now that we have our
yams in a bowl we're gonna mix in our
seasonings so we're gonna take our brown
sugar and then we're gonna use our
cinnamon sugar now this is one of my
cheats and my tips because you can buy
the cinnamon and sugar already mixed
together next we're going to add our
vanilla extract next we're going to use
our vegan butter now you can use
whatever kind of vegan butter you want
you can use a coconut base avocado base
whatever vegan butter you want you just
want to make sure it does not overpower
your dish we're going to mix this all up
you want to make sure that every potato
gets covered in our sugar and butter
mixture we're going to put this right
into our aluminum pan you can use a
glass pan if you want to it just takes a
longer cook time once we put it into our
aluminum pan it's going to help
caramelize the potatoes and it's going
to be absolutely delicious once we get
that spread out into an even layer we're
going to top it with some aluminum foil
i'm going to make sure we have it sealed
up real nice
oh yeah baby oh yeah oh
look at that
[Music]
like this is like big mama house this is
home there you have it we have made our
vegan thanksgiving with five ingredients
we have our southern fried chicken our
maple collards and candy yams i would
love for you to try these recipes at
home so make sure you tag me at
cookingwithjoya and let me know what you
think happy thanksgiving from my family
to yours see you next time ciao
oh yes
[Music]
you